[Musique]
la recette de ma pâte c'est 10 litres
d'eau 20 kg de farine 400 g de sel 40 g
de levure après on les fait faire un
tour seulement un tour
[Musique]
oui il ne faut pas toucher les bords le
bord c'est la pizza avec le bord il ne
faut pas le toucher le bas il faut
laisser un peu bomber au milieu comme ça
ne vient pas très fin au milieu
[Musique]
elle a la plus importante c'est tomate
alors quand on dit
la pizza la pizza on le fait pas avec la
mozza on le fait avec le fleur du lait
ce sont les bases de la pizza sont
presque tous de l'Italie
[Musique]
beaucoup et ils m'ont demandé pourquoi
chez nous elle ne sort pas comme chez
vous ces questions de température et
question de fours professionnels de elle
doit être et pour cuire les ingrédients
[Musique]
c'est non tu ne peux pas le faire à la
maison à la maison elle sort comme un
disque très dur
pourquoi les gens aiment la pizza parce
qu'elle est plus rapide plus rapide de
ça coûte moins cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]